Speaker 1: If you don't understand something,
it's very difficult to be prepared for it,
to know how to synthesize it, to know how to
deal with it. And we are seeing such dangerous
examples of this coming in general from the
divisive narrative being promulgated by the
American right wing in a complete vacuum
of policy, as we've talked about before,
where it's not even that the policy is whatever,
the policy doesn't even matter. They don't even
really talk about policy anymore. And we're
going to look at a couple examples of that
here. And they come from Fox News propagandist
Tucker Carlson. Now, one of the reasons that
Carlson is particularly dangerous is that
similarly to someone like a Ben SHAPIRO.
Tucker Carlson speaks very confidently. The tone
of people like Tucker and Ben SHAPIRO are that
they're extraordinarily confident in telling
you how things are. The reason that Tucker is
arguably even more dangerous than Ben SHAPIRO is
that to some degree, Ben SHAPIRO is more readily
understood as giving his opinion, whereas the
context and the sort of production of Tucker's
show, where it just looks like yet another Fox
News program actually tricks more people into
thinking that Tucker Carlson is giving you news.
And as we know, when it when the rubber meets the
road and the lawyers come out because there's
a lawsuit, Fox News lawyers are very quick to
say Tucker Carlson is an entertainer. He's not
a news person. Look at these couple of clips
from yesterday from Tucker Carlson's program.
In this first clip, Tucker Carlson bemoans,
I guess, what he considers some kind of woke
affirmative action of sorts by pointing out
that Joe Biden has appointed quite a number of
black women to be judges. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: Out of 97 federal judges confirmed
under Joe Biden, total number of white men, five.
22 are black women. So this is race based hiring.
It's illegal, but it's also not about looking
like America. It's about punishing people.
Speaker 1: Now, that could not be less true.
And what Tucker Carlson doesn't tell you when he
says, well, hold on a second. 97 federal judges
confirmed under Biden, 22 were black women.
That's like almost a quarter. That doesn't
make any sense. That doesn't look like America.
But you have to zoom out and you have to realize
there are currently about 1400 sitting federal
judges, 14. And it's actually 1407. More than
half are white men, not just white. More than half
are white men. And only four and a half percent
are black women. So when you say it's illegal,
it's not representative of the way America looks
or whatever the case may be. Understand that
African-Americans make up 13% of the American
population. You would expect if black women and
girls are roughly half of that 13%, that would be
six and a half percent. You still have black women
underrepresented by a third among judges. Now, I
am not someone who says we need exact equality of
outcome. You're never going to have that. It's an
unreasonable thing to expect. If I came to you and
I said, In order for society to be fair in every
single place, we must have 50.3% women, 13% black
people, 1% Jews, or whatever the percentages. And
that would be a very unreasonable thing to say.
But when you zoom out, there are places where
we look and we have to say, this can't be by
chance. When you zoom out and you say, well,
46 presidents and zero women in a country that's
50.3% women, that is a statistic that doesn't make
sense. We don't need a 50.3% of presidents to be
women. You might have a situation where women are
less interested in being president than men, and
it doesn't have to be because of discrimination.
I'm completely open to that. You know, the right
wingers love to say this thing where they go, Hey,
you know what? If you really want equality, why
aren't you fighting for 50.3% of longshoremen?
It actually the term has man in it, right? Why
aren't you fighting for 50.3% of longshoreman
and bricklayers to be women? Well, that that's
not actually what we're saying. And there are
all sorts of different reasons why women may
be less interested in being bricklayers. And
it doesn't have to be because of discrimination.
So it's not about equality of. Outcome. But the
very argument Tucker is making is turned on
its head by the fact Tucker says 22 out of 97
judges being black women isn't representative of
America's demographics. Well, no, but we have such
a deficit demographically among among judges that
what Joe Biden is doing is only partially making
the demographics actually represent America so
that it's a bogus argument, but it's ripe and
perfect for his audience. Here is one other just
clip from yesterday. And again, it's just these
are talking point comas that Tucker goes into
here. It's something about transgender Satanism.
Speaker 2: I'm shameless
about this. I don't even care.
Tonight's transgender Satanism brought to you by
Pfizer and check their products in your body. It's
so great. Chadwick Moore, Awesome.
Speaker 1: That is a very, very concerning laugh.
So, listen, there is horrible stuff happening on
Tucker Carlson's program. And if you were saying,
well, fine. There's horrible stuff happening
there. But Tucker is never going to say, well,
we should be defending George Santos,
is he? Well, let's talk about that next